The Last Airbender is quite possibly the
most confusingly inept film I've ever
seen an adaptation of the Nickelodeon
television series Avatar The Last
Airbender written directed and produced
by M night Shyamalan it's not the worst
morally or technically but it still
baffles me just how bad the final
product is once all the factors are
taken into consideration this is this is
going to be a lazy episode we're we're
not even really going to talk about it
we're just going to [ __ ] and whine in
fact we're going to be super lazy about
it - forget the normal flow this is now
a top X list of whatever you know what
I'm not even going to go back and change
that once I know what the number
actually is
I've got a whole bunch of points to
bring up but the first thing that you're
going to notice is that there's no one
thing wrong with this movie everything
is wrong with it there's no one element
of the production that doesn't have some
kind of deep crippling flaw and these
flaws multiply each other bad acting
makes a bad script worse bad editing
calls attention to bad acting bad
cinematography makes bad editing all the
more unbearable even the parts that
strictly speaking aren't incompetent are
pulled down by everything else
solid animation and effects work looks
terrible when it's combined with clunky
choreography or is just really poorly
stitched together no matter how
realistic your fake lemur looks the
effect is going to look like crap if the
actor is clearly waving their hands at
empty space looking at nothing in
particular
I'm not going to spend a ton of time
harping on this but the movie makes a
lot of really dumb pointless changes to
the source material this is my lump
category for all the little nitpicks
like character names motivations little
details and other crap a lot of other
people have covered these exhaustively
they bug me too but I want to focus on
deeper structural flaws so just consider
this a catch-all if I missed something
put it here first off I realize that
there's going to be certain challenges
with the script for this film because
condensing 500 minutes of television
down to a 100 minute movie isn't going
to be all that easy that said it
shouldn't turn out this bad the overall
pace and flow of the movie is atrocious
I've tried to narrow it down to a few
specifics but the best way to put it is
that it lacks focus the script doesn't
seem to understand what its core story
is who the characters are what drives
them and what it should do with them
the result is a movie that feels like
it's moving way too fast jumping from
scene to scene at a moment's notice but
never seems to actually go anywhere
characters don't so much transition from
place to place as much as they just walk
off stage there's a practical epidemic
of expositional problems as a result
secondary characters prattle on about
meaningless mythology and wax
philosophic while we still don't even
know who the main characters are he'll
the main characters seem to spend most
of their time talking filling in random
backstory or talking about pointless
details like this whole bit at the
beginning Katara
who is in theory the narrator of the
film and co-star despite a dearth of
presence tells us a bunch of stuff about
the Southern Water Tribe how it used to
be a big city her father her mother the
war how hungry they are and for some
reason how her brother isn't a very good
hunter my brother and I often go hunting
for food but unfortunately my brother
isn't the best hunter in the world aside
from the fact that there's a war going
on none of this matters some of it will
be mentioned again but it doesn't make a
difference the fact that Sokka and
Katara's been forced into adulthood at a
young age doesn't influence their
characters at all
in fact neither of them really has
anything that could be called a
character arc even though I've watched
it four times now I'm still hard-pressed
to identify what motivates these
characters like normally this little
exchange about tracking the seal would
be a setup for later on like in the
third act sock has to prove himself by
following someone's tracks or he has to
I don't know
hunt something but know it it never
comes up again like I said before all of
these little bits and pieces intertwine
with one another the script is bad but
it's aggravated by some truly poor
editing this runs the entire gamut
including odd shot choices weird cut
points and nonsensical juxtapositions
the first act of the movie is an unholy
mess it's nonsense
gibberish it's worse than amateur it's
missing all the connective tissue that
ties the story character and various
pieces together there's so many little
wrong moments that I'm having trouble
picking out which ones to mention
because they start to run into each
other
okay so Katara and Sokka bust in out of
this ice ball right you'd assume that
this is where the characters will
introduce each other and we'll set up
the fundamental dynamic between the
three protagonists right like there will
be some wacky hijinx and we'll learn
that Aang is a fun-loving and curious
goofball with mad airbending skills that
Sokka is a big softy who plays tough
because he feels obligated to fill the
void left by his father and the guitar
is smart sensitive fiercely loyal to her
friends and protective of the weak and
downtrodden but what actually happens is
well nothing really I mean they find him
Katara poke sang a couple of times
decides that he needs a nap there's a
gag we're office tail lands on Sokka and
then we're suddenly back in town there's
no transition between locations and no
exchange between characters you think
that bringing a comatose stranger in a
four tonnes six legged bison into town
would draw some attention and questions
you'd think that it'd be the kind of
significant moment that would be perfect
for establishing the setting and
characters as we the audience see how
guitar and Sokka handle the problem and
how they try to explain it to the people
back home instead no information is
exchanged the audience learns nothing
and they apparently teleport back to
home base well okay actually that's not
entirely true there is an establishing
shot but blinked
you'll miss it these two nameless
characters pointed something off-screen
I guess that's them being all amazed at
this crazy thing that's happening over
there to the right somewhere off that
way Wow look at that crazy thing so
crazy okay so in the igloo Katara and
Aang have a boring and inane
conversation where they open their word
holes and make noises at one another but
managed to say nothing of any
consequence oh I see actually guitars
response makes sense if you read it like
someone trying to be polite when
confronted with unintelligible madness
see the fact that Appa can fly hasn't
been established yet so when she asks
how'd you get all the way out here it's
a pretty legit question about how a boy
and a mastodon managed to get out into
the middle of nowhere become entombed in
ice and survived for an indeterminate
period of time because you see this is a
very confusing situation so when he says
I ran away from home as though that more
or less covers all the bases her utter
ly confused response oh oh I see is
actually a pretty believable reaction I
mean no one wants to call ice cube boy a
liar on his first day in town it's still
bad writing though I know it's going
back to the bad script but there's this
running trend where characters will talk
at length about meaningless bullcrap and
then completely gloss over important
information plus he has yet to introduce
himself technically speaking we the
audience don't even know his name
and neither does Katara in fact we don't
learn it for another ten thirteen
minutes is it okay if you tell me your
name
the monks named me on this scene also
introduces two more running problems
that will see through the film poorly
matched shot reverse shot framing and a
hanging action shot reverse shot is a
common setup for editing dialogue in
fact it's so common that it's considered
a basic technique at the fundamental
level the shot in a reverse shot will be
fairly closely matched without getting
too technical or meaty let's just say
that for a neutral conversation between
two characters their heads should be
roughly the same size on screen also for
the sake of interest to create some
urban flow the Edit should mix in of
riah t of different framings some
tighter and some looser this is all part
of the visual language of film close-ups
on an actor's face feel more intense
than looser shots and by moving in and
out through a scene the filmmakers can
communicate how important this bit of
information is relative to that bit of
information what we get here is a shot
reverse shot where Aang is this big and
Katara is this big with zero variation
it's the same two shots through the
entire dialogue also for no real reason
her framing is all wobbly like it's
handheld while he's is locked off this
isn't even the worst case of it that
comes later at the end of Act one where
Sokka and Katara's shot like this and
Aang is shot like this through the
entire conversation why is it so close
to his face wait wait wait let's go back
to the igloo a hanging action hanging
action okay throughout the film
characters will start an action as
though the scene is going to continue
but then the movie cuts away to
something completely different before
they actually do or say whatever it was
that they started doing so anka tarah
have their pointless conversation it
ends and then an reaches over for this
stick and looks at her like he's about
to say something clearly reaching for
this thing was important because the
Edit waited a whole beat for him to even
start the action he stops talking beat
reaches for the stick cut to the Fire
Nation ship this actually like bleeds
right into another example of a lack of
connective tissue devoid of any shot
that places the ship in relation to the
village
Sokka walks into the igloo and says the
Fire Nation is here we don't see him
seeing the ship we don't see the ship in
the background beaching just outside the
village we just see the ship out in the
water the same place that's been the
whole time it's bad editing because it
fails to place important set pieces into
a spatial relationship this crap goes on
and on and on we spend a lot of time
going into slow-mo for the fight scenes
but almost no time indicating the
connection between point a and point B
like this whole mess for Katara in a
voiceover sums up Aang's backstory by
telling us that he told her that he flew
into a storm and fell into the water and
formed an air bubble and doesn't
anything else after that it's like I'm
at rush kadal of bad narrative I mean
for one shouldn't we have learned all
that earlier like during a scene where
they were already explicitly talking
about the subject of where he came from
and - the whole thing is made unbearably
stupid by this line is it okay if you
tell me your name so they flew from the
Antarctic up to this temperate possibly
subtropical mountain range during which
time he told them all about how he came
to get trapped in the ice and at no
point during that trip did they bother
to ask him his name
all this after they've decided to join
him on his mystical journey of unknown
duration and scope god only knows if
they ever got around to telling him
there since we never actually see that
interaction I mean I'm not going to
demand realism for my fantasy films like
I don't need the world of Avatar to be
properly scaled to earth to the point
where this trip takes several days if
not thanks but I still think is going to
take more than a 10 15 minutes to make
this journey also this whole bit and
getting trapped in the ice is kind of
the sort of thing that you should
probably show the audience instead of
just telling them about it
I told us how he left there in a storm
on Appa and got forced into the ocean
where they almost drowned
and to make this even more inept okay so
they have actively dodged around Aang's
named twice up to this point first when
they find him and second when Zuko takes
him captive
he's the titular character they're
withholding the information clearly it's
building up to some meaningful reveal
right no not only does the reveal have
zero impact on Katara or Sokka meaning
that it doesn't mean anything to them
but he just shouts it back at them from
off screen
the monks named me on just I don't even
know did they forget to shoot a reverse
shot did they have this line in the
script and at no point think gee the
title character should probably be on
screen when he finally introduces
himself just Wow okay oh oh and then we
roll from this monstrosity of poor
pacing right into another example of
both poor pacing bad editing terrible
information flow and a hard tone shift
really most of the information that they
exchanged here the temple should have
been brought out like 10-15 minutes
earlier back at the South Pole you know
maybe have the main characters talk and
build some rapport with one another
before heading off on their grand
adventure keeping in mind that based on
all the information we've been given
Sokka and Katara's after Katara alone
has had a microscopic conversation with
aim seriously back in the igloo they
only had like eight lines of dialogue
but here they are at the air temple and
just now is Katara bothering to ask any
questions in an attempt at piecing
together Aang's very obviously hole
filled story there is some terrible
interaction with a CG lemur and then BAM
the killing fields of Cambodia this
should be a suspenseful moment leading
up to the reveal but it's not because
one it happens too fast and two we have
no reason to care we've barely been
introduced to Aang and our surrogate
characters have only just pieced
together that there's some bad juju
waiting up ahead
even better the movie gets around to
telling us why we should care after it's
too late for us to care oh and after
this scene they just teleport again
there's the fourth freakout moment we
cut away to the fire nation stuff and
when we come back to our protagonist
they've traveled an indeterminate
distance to an unknown place
apparently instantaneously this is a
running flaw but it's made worse by the
fact that they actually get it right
sometimes see when they leave the South
Pole there's a short travel montage as
they fly to the air temple and we see
them arrive at the air temple this is
important because it's connective tissue
it tells us the audience the time is
passing and space is being covered this
is pretty basic editing it doesn't need
to eat up a lot of time but it's
critical to properly communicating the
temporal spatial elements of the story
which is pretty important in this case I
mean it's quite literally a hero's
journey from the South Pole to the North
Pole what they've built is a roadtrip
story where the characters are never in
the car
our main characters don't really
interact with one another
sure sure they do stuff together sort of
but for the most part they just talk at
one another and do things in proximity
all of the interesting stuff like
chatter playing arguing plotting
confiding and celebrating happens off
screen and we're just told about it
after the fact often in voiceover my
brother in the princess became friends
right away really because that sounds
like it would have been fun to see we
could have watched them share some witty
banter flirt a bit go on a date of sorts
and do something other than glanced
furtively at one another also let's talk
about our main character for a second
particularly his little freakout moment
so he's walking through the bones and
sees the medallion he made for his old
master then he flips his lid goes all
Super Saiyan we're supposed to care
about this moment get invested in his
loss it's in theory setting up Aang's
character but in practice Aang has only
had about 20 lines of dialogue up to
this point total almost all of which has
been expository in the weakest way
possible it's almost impossible to care
about hang at this point because he's a
one-way street he rattles off whatever's
on the top of his mind but doesn't seem
to care if anyone's actually listening
or if they understand him or if they
even care he doesn't even ask their
names
this doesn't get any better as the movie
goes on and rarely actually interacts
with other characters in any meaningful
way and doesn't really seem to notice
that they're even in the same room as
him it's kinda like my father well that
kind of egocentrism makes for a very
believable ten-year-old it's not a very
engaging trait for a protagonist
the dialogue is just atrocious and the
deliveries make it all the worse here
are some of my favorite worst exchanges
he's exhausted
hey Jinzo mone I'm back
hey guys this is okay if you tell me
your name ah she's a bender I ran away
but I'm back now
ah the avatar would have to be an
airbender are you an airbender boy
should we try it yes we should
ah this new practice area my brother and
the princess became friends right away
ah ah again I offer my condolences on
your nephew burning to death in that
terrible accident
is there a spiritual place where I can
meditate ah there's a very spiritual
place the city was built around this
place as your brother Fire Lord Ozai and
I have decided it isn't our best
interests to kill the moon spirit ah ah
we can be friends ah
belief that my life force will leave my
body and return to the moons and then
what my soul will no longer exist in
this form they want you to be their
avatar
we're going to play the blame game and
the person to blame is Shyamalan hey
foldy yes fictional viewer being used as
a rhetorical device isn't that a little
harsh movies are a collaborative effort
how can you say something is entirely
one person's fault well okay I'll pull
my punch a bit I wasn't there so I can't
say for sure that Shyamalan pulled rank
or whatever and wound up pissing in the
stewpot but let's take a moment to look
at all the department heads and see if
we can identify a weak link seriously
he's the most likely problem I spent a
lot of time bitching about the editing
so I guess we should take a look at the
editor Conrad buff probably isn't
someone who's ever caught your attention
and frankly his editing isn't anything
how-to no exceptional like he's hardly
the kind of editor that you'd think of
as an artist elevating the craft of
editing by weaving complex visual tales
but at the same time it's very likely
that you're familiar with his work in
fact his work basically defines the
typical Hollywood style if you're
thinking of straightforward no-frills
competent high-quality mainstream
invisible editing what's on his resume
only a couple dozen big-budget
mainstream effects driven films
including species Terminator 2 Titanic
True Lies Dante's Peak Terminator
Salvation & Rise of the Planet of the
Apes the dude clearly knows what he's
doing and can tell an intelligible story
with whatever he's given alright so
maybe it's the cinematographers fault
then maybe the DOP didn't get enough
coverage didn't bother to shoot a
variety of framings leaving mr. buff
with nothing to work with that's a
possibility right fat chance
Andrew lesney is an equally well
seasoned professional and the kind of
DOP that I would describe as an artist
you probably know him as the Oscar
winner who shot over 6 million feet of
film for the Lord of the Rings not only
is he a longtime veteran of the craft
but he's also incredibly familiar with
lighting blocking and framing incredibly
complicated scenes weaving together
actors green-screen and conventional
effects while still getting the coverage
needed for the editor to tell a story we
actually have a litmus test for how
these two department heads fit together
because they have worked too
whether on another project after Last
Airbender they both worked on Rise of
the Planet of the Apes which is a
perfectly competent film it certainly
isn't plagued with hanging actions lack
of coverage and weird framing choices
you
okay so the key creative decision-making
roles in a film are the cinematographer
the editor the director the writer the
producer and sometimes the lead actors
this isn't an actor driven movie so we
can assume that by and large the cast
showed up did their job and collect
their paycheck we've already eliminated
the editor and cinematographer as
suspects so that leaves the director
writer and producer hey if you want to
take all the credit you get to take all
the blame
like up